pour répondre à la question que vous
avez posé qu'est-ce que je regrette
c'est que tous les nouveaux bâtiments il
est pas trop tard soit tous à énergie
positive qu'est-ce que c'est un bâtiment
énergie positif même moi j'avais donné
au territoire et il y en a quelques-uns
qui sont déjà construits notamment des
logements c'est un bâtiment qui produit
au moins autant d'énergie qu'il n'en
consomme
quand même extraordinaire donc vous avez
vous arrivez dans ces bâtiments la
facture des gens c'est 3 euros 4 euros
par mois parce que le bâtiment produit
autant d'énergie qu'il en consomme alors
ça veut dire des panneaux solaires sur
le toit quand c'est possible ça veut
dire la récupération de la chaleur ça
veut dire des performances énergétiques
exceptionnelles et dis surtout des
récupérations de chaleur le long des
circuits on maîtrise les technologies
donc ça ça pourrait être répandu c'est à
dire quand vous allez dans la salle de
chaudière la récupération de chaleur
elle est pas perdue elle est récupérée
et il y a même des bâtiments où on
récupère la chaleur dans les cuisines
quand vous faites votre cuisine il y a
de la chaleur cette chaleur est
récupérée et recycler pour qu'il n'y ait
zéro perdition de chaleur donc c'est
aussi des des technologies à développer
et qui sont maîtrisés
et surtout l'isolation des toitures des
portes des fenêtres et des façades c'est
des technologies qu'on maîtrise et donc
il est parfaitement possible de
construire des bâtiments à énergie
positives aujourd'hui